oh oh okay yeah I forgot this time right
okay English I think it starts like
straight away so I'm just like oh I'm
just gonna go yeah I just make it a
little brighter always make it brighter
mint mint brightness I don't know to the
button that's very bit of somewhere like
this yeah fine um what yeah yeah send my
data to the net okay
okay now the time is up right okay okay
uh uh I know it hasn't started yet I'm
just freaking out I'm because I opened
it on my PC and it started counting down
when it was on the brightness and stuff
menu well maybe it didn't know I was
just freaking out
well that means I can play it twice
right it's supposed to be a short break
for Leon as Kennedy just one last pit
stop of gas station on the outskirts of
town when the rookie cop found himself
running an air in the sea of zombies
along with a newfound friend Claire
Redfield Leon managed to escape to
Raccoon City only for an accident to
split them apart Nathalie navigating
through the perilous streets
Leon has made his way to cities were a
little off safety like let's go yes
combined Oh with okay
what's this
thing is I you I don't usually speedrun
a game so this is so weird for me Oh
stay away from the zombie okay I gotta
get to the break room let me know if the
audio is okay guys okay I don't know
don't even then yeah that's it don't
need any of that clap right
I know apparently we can go outside can
we go out this door
is this the dog years
haha right alone I won't waste this is
cool but yeah okay I should probably go
back inside fight let's do our thing let
our body sighing this looks exactly like
in um it wasn't evil seven okay so how
do I get that back up like this okay and
how do i ii can i I don't need it now
anyways okay
ah this is a puzzle I need okay but if
we did we go where did where do we go go
you get to the break room right which is
over this side of the building Oh
hmm can't go in there
do-do-do-do-do I'm gonna turn up the
audio a tiny bit so let me know if it's
too much of the game I mean I don't know
I don't know I don't know okay so we
have to find this something relevant to
that that's gonna help us with that
puzzle fork I'm not doing a very good
speedrun here am i yeah Nikki oh thank
you
oh that's nice then
come on Leon you're you're a young
whippersnapper you shouldn't be making
all these grunts huh
this doors down here's this this is look
around bloody how they're all locked you
don't have a knife for that Oh Oh Donna
I just wasted a hell of a lot time in
awesome man
oh okay I like this gonna do something
here are getting the fuse
oh I love just the dramatic difference
of the room before hello
and this one I can hardly see hello
you got this Leon you got this okay
I think Ricketts what's this
lights ah yes oh hello okay well thanks
for the ammo sorry about the untimely
death but at least you're not a zombie
okay how are we gonna get through here
can we get through here hmm
I think that's all we can do in here
Oh
we're holder shoot man
mmm which way which way I don't know
let's just go down this way
fork it yeah there's a lot of dead
people around here okay
wait can we shoot it no what what which
tour this one
Oh
okay
mMmmm I mean oh she's not laughs that's
great ooh doodles
I like a doodle oh yeah of course
so you gotta you gotta go under this oh
yeah yeah time I forget about the
unicorn wait this is to help us okay so
maybe if this is [ __ ] success as a
lion lion and the lamb a unicorn and a
harp and what wasn't then what's the
bird all about crown I don't know to me
trying to be smart with puzzles return
to the main hall okay let's do this Oh
Oh God how do I know it's both a
freaking bit me dude you're not gonna be
okay he beat you I need a head shot okay
he beat you there's not only you're
about to turn how does this how does
this work oh go back to the main hall
headshot what
oh my god just frickin run just go for
it
oh my god where did I go oh my god Who
am I where am i what is life this way ah
what am i doing I got some bullets
that's nice no stay what no stay away no
I can't see I don't know what I'm doing
I think I'm gonna dead end
zombies are everywhere oh my god
exit exit exit exit exit exit
the do like embed it does that mean I'm
infected I don't know how it works
oh thank you so this was the dude but he
couldn't move before in the last game
right and now he's a badass she's saving
us from zombies
does anyone else started this
but honestly all you need to know is
that this place will eat your body
yeah I know I'm not I just I've already
dog I'll call it stay away hope should
come here sooner uh he looks very young
and tiny okay lieutenant all right
out of the station that officer you met
over le he thought this secret passage
with my can be tricky
this is good news we can get you to a
hospital
this is the exact same sketch that I
picked up ready antenna I'm not just
gonna leave you here I'm giving you an
order
rookie you save yourself first I've come
with you but I just
you'll need this
don't take stop
and don't make my mistake
if you see one of those things uniform
yes sir got it
oh wait I'm not supposed to be skipping
this I don't even know how to skip them
anyways I don't think again forgetting
them on a timer
they're just like enjoying it too much
right ready and slash slash slash slash
Thanks what your job okay
I'm gonna miss you but it's um what
happens here then yeah I need to get
them modality anything's
so does that book well that book helped
us complete whatever the hell this is
huh
excuse me
crown lamb harp unicorn bird
yeah this makes perfect sense right okay
so add the hop is like here wears a
crown oh hey a crown harp ready red bird
bird bird
maybe this night so much okay unless it
was mm-hmm
goat cuz I saw the goat thing here where
are you gone well doesn't it go in here
okay well fair enough maybe this one's a
goat then darn it
what we got here we got a girl I don't
know
this is uh what was in that there was
definitely a bird in there oh dude oh
dude oh dude your day um wait oh no whoo
puzzles puzzles will be the end of me um
just pointing to the crown and then to
the goat maybe it's just the bird the
girl on the harp
no sir is oh there's a lion - wait cone
a lion and RAM so it's just everything
on the first page okay cool
oh I guess that would make sense uh she
cuz it's a freaking line right so we
have the first medallion and now what do
we do we need skill else we're just
given more rooms
but these are stills out
mm-hmm tell me where to go tell me what
to do oh wait put it down
um okay hold up use it that way I was
just gonna be like yeah
which did
yeah I mean talk about throwing you in
the deep end hello herb
blast from the past okay yes
where's money isn't that supposed to be
a little birthday party scene where it's
like welcome first day oh oh come on
PlayStation right
can I get down in under here nope
are you a zombie are you a zombie
put it down put it down oh oh this is
good
oh wait where is it where's the the
liquor what am I supposed to do
something here I should be running I
guess but how's your wanting nope nope I
guess I'm supposed to boarding them up
but I don't have anything to hold them
up with out shy side manizer in the
table ah okay I think this is all me in
here I heard one where rather maybe not
okay good
what's this huh oh yes what is happening
I can't I can't I'm sorry I'm sorry I
can't
yep great lovely
ah nice cool no it's just go okay hi bye
yes no maybe go do not hesitate
oh Jesus stop freaking missing you know
ah okay so let's go in this door oh
Jesus he wasn't daddy's astronomy
now you're dead Jesus
what is actually really unnerving
because you can't really see very well
but you can just hear so many zombies oh
okay so let's board you up I think this
is a safe room I don't worry with this
this seems like I've been here before so
maybe I am remembering parts of this
game I don't know
gunpowder oh I know what herbs are you
no need to tell me I can't say it
because demo all right okay I don't need
this for now I don't think I need that
one either
what's this ooh red herb thank you
what's this what is this for pictures
right yeah I will use one of these
[Music]
sit another half no that's just a
flowers right let's go
nope nope don't know um let's go into my
locker room
cuz I got the I got key right huh
ah Jesus Christ should be reading things
and I probably find the code to that but
whatever it doesn't matter anyway
Oh where's the shotgun where's the
shotgun
give me a shotgun I guess it's probably
in here if I can get in oh so annoying
okay what am i doing
twice's yeah sure sure hmm I want the
shotgun I use only
don't know what's happening can I go
let's go up some stairs there's some
some angry zombies around oh okay that I
don't know what they are I have a lot of
bullets now this is good where the
bloody hell are you what are you doing
oh yeah I don't know any of this woo I
think that's the key back in the main
room right I think I think I don't know
Oh Bulls um okay well that's wait hold
up oh what a what an interesting
figurine um
oh shut up let's just wait can I
combined this with this mixed Arabs okay
yeah
no wonder what wasn't the what now what
I think I miss something too busy just
running around like a freakin idiot
no oh spooky spooky spooky should I just
go back to my uh I can't be ass I'm fine
it's fine we don't need anything you
don't need those cardboards study places
to go I don't hello
why okay let me just check out this room
first Marvin
hello
although behind that door right okay Oh
God
nothing up no no it's a lie it's a trap
what's Joe oh my god they're freaking
everyone oh yeah God like it's obvious
oh no I've lost my knife oh my god
they're everywhere
just climb just climb just keep climbing
just keep climbing okay wait what am i
doing
oh okay
I can't sit down for long I need to go
back to my little buddy bud what's this
dial lock huh let me just go back to my
friend so screw it let's just go back
the way we came
oh my god that's so creepy
oh they can store more things oh don't I
don't care about some guys discover
things I don't have the time for this
Oh was this yes yes it was always good
there's always helpful
um okay time to you're back
this way there was probably a quicker
way to get back but I know I'm just
going to do what I know where is he
right just run just read this one just
one you're okay you're okay you're okay
you're okay you're okay there's another
one here there no no it's missing spot
no it's cuz I'm streaming it from my
PlayStation cuz I messed up and I think
I triggered the timer on my PC one okay
Jesus Christ where am I going how am I
going
I just get the main hole so straight and
then laughs this way yeah Oh huh think
of this one what it's not oh but then
this is not our way it must be
yeah good I'm okay again shite I got
lost
so need to get through here somehow
balls okay
yeah don't you dare get back up any of
this stuff oh I do have a key card for
something they don't I for this
[Applause]
shotgun shotgun time oh yeah baby yeah
yes um oh nice nice nice this makes me
very happy
die [ __ ] um okay back to finding out
whether how I'm going ah so I need to go
I don't know all the way kind of over
this way right no not this way this way
no like I said nowhere this way no not
that way so this way but it's blogs I
still understand just [ __ ] [ __ ] I don't
even know like how I got yeah oh but I
found the shotgun I don't want it I
don't want it to be ended
that was sucky oh I mean I'm glad I
found the shotgun just in time I killed
one zombie with a shotgun so that was
fun ah that was good that was good I'm
actually really excited for the release
now because it's it's slightly different
to present evil seven because there's
more action involved which is obviously
the premise of Resident Evil anyway that
you know you actually have all these
guns you can actually kill things and
you're not too overpowered but at the
same time you just kind of want to run
and just go places because you've got to
solve puzzles and everything ah for that
yeah that was good hopefully you guys
enjoyed now watch the trailer do you
want do you want us to watch the trailer
we I guess we could do that
[Music]
show me the things you have sex again
yeah I want to find out what's happening
here she's the one umbrella responsible
for unleashing the virus seems to be
evolving faster Thanks be kidding me god
only knows what's down here plus
nah
ah the tofu flock love it love it yes
yes yes yes it's gonna be great this is
gonna be great you know uh
I haven't got the money spot yet but
don't worry as soon as I can
I'm gonna be getting it this is too much
action this is not Horace as the sort of
production well this is like this is
what Resident Evil was though you know
it was um there's there's just survival
horror I think that's probably what
you're thinking about I really like
survival horror as well but that's more
your very overpowered and it's a lot
about kind of hiding and sneaking and
whatever but with Resident Evil I mean
you are a cop so you have guns and
whatever you don't start off being
underpowered because you're already in
that position of power but obviously I
mean with the virus outbreak it just
goes crazy and yeah but no I'm super
excited I'm super excited like I said I
didn't play this game as much when I was
a kid I'm all played it with my friends
whenever I'm around her house cuz I
wasn't allowed to play this then I say
that I did used to play a lot of I don't
know if anyone ever played
I learned the dark a new nightmare on
ps1 that was out around the same time as
like the Resident Evil's but I used to
play that a lot with a friend who lived
closer so and that was more of a
survival horror I guess because you were
very overpowered in that but yeah and
then Sun hills is frickin love Sam Hills
well
oh my gosh whoa thank you so much mantas
rather than evil fund yes I will make
sure it gets towards buying wasn't evil
so you obviously enjoyed it so hopefully
it for you and yeah hopefully I'll be
like Resident Evil 7 you know we stayed
up all night you remember that we didn't
all night livestream playing Resident
Evil 7 up until it was something like 5
a.m. and then I remember my housemate
phoned me and I needed to pick her up
because she was out drinking so I stayed
in with you guys and we raised like 200
pounds for charity I think that was that
wasn't good stream that was a good
stream nice big blue comment says Jeff
Kirsten I don't know why we do talk like
that
I remember the original having grenade
launchers magnums automatic rifles and
other powerful weapons to shoot enemies
yeah so Resident Evil's always been a
bit more that way and that's why they
they did go very much into the actions
side of things and then I just lost
interest then
I wasn't ready into the whole military
style and they just really made it more
of an action game because I remember was
like what game would I play I think it
was Resident Evil 5 with my friend cuz
that was that the one that you could
play multiplayer and I just I just kind
of felt like I was playing an action
game but I don't really feel like I
staying a horror game sunhill 2 3 & 4
are you asking me which one I prefer
Wesker because if I mmm for the
mechanics I would save well for like the
narrative style of things and like the
mechanics and stuff like I would say for
I mean the gameplay mechanics weren't
like gameplay I mean the blue blur
they're like battle what am I trying to
say
those kind of mechanics weren't that
good but I love the whole the premise
of being in a hotel room that you are
actually locked within on the inside
that is slowly getting more and more
haunted and also that you can peek out
and you feel like you're a prisoner even
in your safe space did the whole that
just blew my mind and I just think that
brought it to a whole new level of
horror because you know in in like
Resident Evil if you have your safe
rooms and your places like you feel safe
all the time but then in some Hill the
room you kind of thought that that was
your safe very safe place but then as
the game progressed it just messed with
you and then you realized that Noah was
safe and it's just yeah it it was very
cool what actually there was an unreal
PT sunhill P what
unreal PT Sam Hill PT reborn what the
bloody hell are you talking about a P
unreal PC son Hill PT played one what
woohoo thanks for following way
it's your name just wave what's your
name
Albert Albert thank you for following
Oh Wesker you said son he'll raise your
favor and then sudden he'll fall consent
I know a lot people that just don't rate
something he'll fall but I think it's
cool I can see how some people think
that they it wasn't initially supposed
to be a sudden Hill for game because I
guess it doesn't really go in with the
law of it it's completely different but
I enjoyed someone remade PT with Unreal
Engine Oh none yes no I heard about this
it's on itch isn't it actually I'm gonna
look for it right now cuz if it's on
edge then I need to play it before
Konami get their hands on it and take it
down and PT remake oh my gosh oh my gosh
maybe we could say that oh whoa I need
to stop recording I've just gone
rambling for like the longest time um
which one is it there seems to be loads
is it this one
is that the one by r-two let me browse
unreal PT this is the one all this look
there's loads and loads of like
different ones radius the radius godello
unreal PT I'm real pretty
yeah are completely recreating the
atmosphere and gameplay of the original
PT oh thank you
Howard Konami not taking this down yeah
I don't know but I'm very happy about it
oh my gosh she's also got development
logs and everything I'm gonna read
through these apparently it's 95%
perfect the only one thing I would
really want to see added or patched him
when with you into the bathroom when
it's open a crack the mother does not
pop out for a sec the door just randomly
closes okay so there's just like some
bits that are just a little bit off mmm
I can't wait I'm so excited
whoo perfection took you here thank you
for fighting for pension I need to like
update that game so bad
and just keep working on it yeah
oh I have I have been working on it
every Christmas but now I've got this
new job oh maybe like next weekend cuz I
need to do some stuff today for the new
job that maybe next weekend I can find
some time or maybe some time after work
I don't know so I made the game in unity
and now I need to like there and unveil
so next game will be in unreal I was
thinking of just starting my own project
so anyway because the best way to learn
something is just like jump in just jump
in and do it Konami take him down so you
have one week what do you mean one week
what if they took it down it wouldn't
still be they're going to work I'm
confused what new job I got I got I'm
getting me one gonna be I am being
trained up as a game designer so it's
like literally my tunes also I need to
like focus and spend a lot of time on
that but obviously I'll be I'll still be
doing all this with you guys but I just
especially for these first few months I
just might not be around as much because
I've really just oh you guys have a get
it where you just want to like prove
yourself so bad you're like thank you
for choosing me and I don't know that's
just me as me as a human being I'm like
just do my best just do my best just
keep trying
yeah I know yeah apparently Konami they
didn't they get in touch though with
someone who was super close to be making
PT and then they offered him a job which
is kind of cool you know what you Becca
is getting a new job as well that's so
cool
enjoy your new job I hope it goes well
hope you enjoy it
Konami taking the game about one week
right understand I think you're trying
to say Konami are going to take the game
down in about week didn't we get that
from though you just are you just
guessing
what you thought on the epics or the
game developer I don't know I don't
really have many thoughts because I
haven't really looked into many places I
just used H for perfection obviously but
Division two isn't going to be released
on Steam is it it's just gonna be
released on the epic game store and you
play as well so that's pretty
interesting so I do I should probably
look into that a bit more but yeah if
you want to play Division two you can't
get it on Steam which is weird cuz get
all games on Steam I can stream while
I'm making my game yes well though that
is yeah damn man I will do it more but
it is terrifying during like game dev
live streams so I remember when I was
doing it around for my degree there was
like some comments that were like you're
not gonna pass your degree with this and
I was just so sleep-deprived just trying
like to hold it together one stream like
please Lee really oh it's funny but ya
know I guess like now the my grade and
stuff it's not a thing I guess it
wouldn't be as touchy about it
Oh Montes as the markets changing it's
getting competitive as steam charges a
lot to have a game in store that's very
good point that's why I well no that's
not why I wasn't see that's why I didn't
put perfection on it I didn't put
professional no because I didn't think I
was good enough but ya know I can see
that I can see that hmm
Division one steam had to launch it via
you play oh I didn't realize that Neal
yeah because obviously it would be on
you play because you know Ubisoft but
interesting hmm yeah yeah your new job
sounds awesome what exactly were you
doing um well at the moment I'm just
training up so I might just try and
learn things and there's so much to
learn so like get home and get so tired
but it's really good thing I just I'm
just like I just know it already you
know the first one I was like I just
want to be good already she's like you
can't doesn't work like that
but yeah I'm just learning um mainly
technical design so figuring out kind of
what you want the player to do or how
you want mechanics to work and then
breaking that into building blocks and
then putting that functionality together
so it's kind of like when I thought
about how I was gonna make perfection I
thought about what the main mechanics
were so the different ways that you
could play the game and then how I was
going to make that happen so what needed
what actions needed to be logged how
they could be logs how that then would
change the mechanics how I was going to
set up the mechanics to be ready for the
changes and then you prototype them with
code but and I'm real they use
blueprints
you don't have to use blueprints you C++
but they have blueprints and that's what
the designers used to like quickly
prototype code so it's a it's quite
different to unity so that's what I'm
learning at the moment
yeah
okay she's Tonko right I think I'm gonna
go now
I'm gonna leave the house I think her
and he'll fit and then do a bit more
work but thank you so much for hanging
out and playing the Resident Evil demo
with me maybe maybe I'll sing should I
sing maybe don't know what is what's the
same what
Esmond you're almost up 30,000 30,000
what do you ml well you were well no I'm
not shushing hush Chewbacca you were
lying
I'm not 20,000 I think I'm pretty sure I
don't know try not to look at numbers
cuz I get like it can get weird where
you just think about numbers much better
just look at just look at the chat just
look at the chat can you play something
for us what you mean a song or a game
because I do need to go because I need
to I need to do some work today and I I
need to play some games for research but
I do also need to do some more unreal
stuff okay you want sing anything but
hit or miss okay okay bye heart Reaper
thanks for popping in what should I play
actually cuz I've been learning the
guitar maybe I'll try and play a bit of
guitar for you
this could go this gives your badge just
saying this could go bad
[Music]
already the lady I lived with to place
the top stop
[Music]
Jona play some just dance later because
she's just gonna tape dog [ __ ] no wait I
might embarrass myself one stream okay
um oh okay don't don't mess up I'm
probably gonna mess up
[Music]
would he use the piercing never I can
vote bad here would write the songs and
I tremble at his hand Bhutto ha ha ha
last four words it can't sicken songs
represent sicken he's a failure now used
to be the life and soul of everyone
around you'd never catch and looking up
and never seem down below curious a
smile not for a while and he's a failure
now
[Music]
don't write you got some smart boy don't
cry aha got something I would die from
and if it comes to the rain just be glad
you'll smile again so many towns and so
many co unnamed people pushed right past
me shouting there exclaims a preacher
purchased me aside and asked to wash my
sins I said no if he made me and his
imagine he's a failure too and it used
to need a couple people keep my head
down now I need to hold them all to keep
me on the ground
hahaha I can you have something and I
gave it up for nothing
now I'm a failing now
[Music]
don't cry tryouts got so much more
effort
don't cry Taha got something I'm tied
for and if it comes to the ring just be
glad you'll smile highly gang summoning
doll so many go on name
[Music]
it's getting there
it's getting there slowly but surely yes
man yeah yay Laura Marling you knew
Albert no no II don't know oh man toss I
mean the ultimate sacrifice started
learning guitar and steel string
ouch you like the real life max hey yeah
that's cute
I could meet max max is cute lots of us
- confirmed
cute does anyone remember filthy Frank I
was like playing I can't do the plucking
very well this is like gotta get like Oh
actually I need this on here random crap
[Music]
give me reasons away she should be
comple you should be with him you should
be with him I can't comfy you should be
[Music]
you look to me someone
[Music]
[Music]
in that time in the but ya know that
strumming time with Tony bro I need to
like lock it lock it lock it drove a
capo yes my friend Tom got me a capo for
a Christmas oh thank you Tom
not here though how could we forget pad
the swing yes
yeah I know your head so weird
I actually over Christmas I went through
a stage you know where you just like go
back to childhood and I just started
watching like um filthy Frank videos and
max my phone and I was like oh this is
my childhood but yeah it's so weird to
see like how cool he is now um it's like
a totally different person
[Music]
do you found in some sort of amp for
your EP I know you have mentioned some
time ago that you'd like to do a venue
maybe I mean I do have some contacts but
I'm really bad live because I get really
nervous and I start to shake and then I
can't play very well but then sometimes
I get over it and then I get into it and
it's really good
but other times it's horrible because I
just I just shake throughout the entire
performance so I don't know but then I
was thinking like maybe I could just do
a livestream event like I'm much better
at that but we'll see we'll see I might
talk to some of my contacts and see what
I can do about it
can't you see
[Music]
[Music]
that's Lucy rose if I can just keep
[ __ ] the right freakin swing man
[Music]
you didn't might nights I thought you
could do it yeah but that's where I
shake like I shake so bad and I can't do
it unless all my friends are there like
cheering me on cuz then I just yeah but
like even my friends are like you could
tell you're so nervous at them I'm like
I know it's so embarrassing it's so
embarrassing um but yeah I know maybe I
mean I just don't feel like I am very
good like I'm I like singing I'm just
really bad at guitar and ukulele it's
just not my thing it's just not my thing
but like I try and that's the main thing
I try I try and as long as you're trying
yeah then that's that's the main thing
isn't it yasmin do you have a favorite
filthy Frank video mm I mean I don't
know I don't really have a favorite I
cannot really watch those like the cake
ones I just can't that's a bit too much
for me goes a bit too far for me goes a
bit too far Oh see harity you say that
your brother gets over stage by getting
a bit drunk I can't do that because I
feel like if I have one drink I just
can't play at all so I literally if I'm
not enough my tonight a bulk drink I
won't drink oh I'll get like one pint
and I'll be like tiny sipping it and it
will last me two hours and then I play
and I have water by me and then I finish
playing and I've been so nervous that I
just like literally just chug the rest
of my beer
it's like my am my little reward to
myself I'm much better sometimes I have
played with other people though and it's
really nice like I played with some of
my friends who play guitar and then they
play a guitar and I sing and it's just
really nice because you're there with
someone else and you don't just up on
your own but yeah that's that's nice
I have been also working on a song but
the plucking I haven't so
it's so weird I think over Christmas I
was just working so hard on trying to
get the the EP designs done and like
getting ready for this job and I was
working perfection as well I know I
haven't updated it yet but honest
honestly I've made some some quite big
changes that I just stopped playing
music and I was like oh my gosh I
haven't played my ukulele in like the
longest time do you like idubbbz cause I
like light ups but you wanna like cause
I like items I like them all
but yes I haven't played in so long so
I'm like but yeah there's this song and
I know I need to change the past and
when I get to the last breath so I'm not
too sure what to do with it yet but I'll
work it out I'll work it out but yeah
this I guess
[Music]
but I think I'm just gonna pluck it I
don't know we'll see
[Music]
everything you wanted doesn't match up
to what you saw everything you need to
everything you were so hard for you
might have your money but coaches can
keep you on stress and the late nights
you pushed away like a peon oh you
deserve and everything I wanted
everything the pans at my koi everything
I need her everything I stifle for the
core I don't have much money but I have
something worth so much more a future to
grass if your hand will unpress don't I
deserve
[Music]
and everything we wanted I know it has
changed from before in our minds you're
planted a vision of a life we can't
afford will waste all our money on what
you have shown a will more it as our own
fill us with floors so we're over course
tell us we deserve
Oh
your member fears fight with every
wrinkle you age did you see every moment
within your choice you made to replace
those who care with eyes that glare
judgment keeps us time to replace our
dreams with something far more Monday
[Music]
we deserve more like that I